l'essai je vais vous montrer alors après
que j'en ai montré depuis plusieurs
jours c'est éric il a 53 ans il est
toujours en quête d'amour et c'est le
maxsym déni du droit c'est le mec qui
passe au travail avec les meubles ou le
gars nous montre des photos de lui jeune
mais vous allez voir que le gars a le
même look 25 ans plus tard en fait il
n'a pas changé il a toujours été mieux
dans la série un trio regarder fellini
quand je me présentais vous rendez vous
ressembler à ça là j'avais une j'avais
28 30 ans pas maté celui-ci ça dépend ça
dépend pour qui des fois j'avais du
succès des fois j'en avais pas ou alors
attendez pour séduire et les qui
s'inscrit un speed dating et le gars il
en galère avec la fille regard des
galères de ouf
vous vous avez une technique de drague
oui quoi vous réveillez votre technique
de drague roth
moi je suis assez directe jeu ah oui je
crois pas je propose tout de suite
est ce que vous êtes opérationnel alors
voilà je suis une meuf par exemple
bonsoir
enfin oui est-ce que tu bois tu prends
un père qui lui valut bike et suédois
dont j'ai déjà
attention si désolée j'ai plein de trucs
de pigeons mais non alors il est le seul
à distance ou fnac alors ça bonsoir
michèle save as tu fait on fait quoi
après mois après ouais ouais non non on
fait quoi on sait quoi
oui mais je sais pas ça dépend par le
mois un peu tôt nous on va perdre du
temps et coûte et l'intrus 4 proposait
je crois qu'il a proposées musique il
raccompagne chez toi parce que tu vois
pas qui a déjà accompagné donc
s'aggraver les rapides en avait pas
vraiment le cas dans ta vie délais la
nouvelle chefferie et il réveillé d'un
coup ses partenaires machine m'a choqué
lui il est très rapide pour que c'est
pour noyer défi mais au foot où vous de
la vie doivent vous l'avez jamais vu est
ce mec là au foot
moi je lui ai pas lui donner quand ce
n'est pas lui c'est vrai au foot ce
n'est pas lui habite et travaille là bas
moi non mais c'est pas possible ou
m'étais peut-être une bouteille de
whisky dans la course et l'avait fait
court 6 courts et très vite au basket il
est bon ça au basket si les bonhommes il
est vachement bon sport 2 masculin que
c'est parce que c'est l'entraînement
j'ai le rythme et la danse
la drague aussi j'ai le rythme et la
danse
j'aime bien juppé il a attendu beauté
une ruse pour se réveiller
c'est un truc de ouf ce gars alors
regardez eric comment il prendrait des
ratons rien ses choix
ouais je vais attendre cette attente
bonsoir je t'ai vu au loin j'avais envie
de te dire bonjour passe normalement
était trop jeune pour moi je suis un peu
cavalier mais je veux qu'on sorte de
cette semaine était dispo jeudi l'écho
ce match philippe salle rit parce qu'ils
mangent
c'était libre
eva comprise et tin économie chose que
je ferai
oui mais quand tu es toi ça c'est du
passé
sendra sera quand tu prends ça dans la
gueule next